let's kick off friday with an exclusive
interview with las vegas basketball
royalty okay we are talking about
olympic gold queens asia wilson and
chelsea gray of the vegas aces they stop
by our radio show over at mix 94.1 to
talk about the current season their
experience at the olympics i love these
ladies here is mercedes with more
i am here with chelsea gray and asia
wilson from your las vegas aces first
place las vegas aces how does that feel
ladies it feels great we still got work
to do though there's a lot of pressure
on you guys being in first place i mean
everyone wants someone at the top how do
you feel going into these last few games
yeah i think i honestly said in the
locker room i was like we've always had
this pressure and this target on our
back even if we were a 12th team so it's
something that we're used to so we're
just going to continue to do us like
we're not going to change up anything
that got us to this first place we're
just going to do us
as far as the teams in the wnba do you
feel like the las vegas aces kind of
have a target on their back just because
you guys have always been so strong
um i actually did you weren't you were
targeting them uh yeah yeah the new new
new kids on the block i'm just like nah
they're just not gonna come in here
now being a part of it definitely you
know people root against the first place
team for sure how was that chelsea
coming onto this team when you used to
go against each other and now you guys
have to play together um i never wanted
to lose against them
i was trying to take away stuff that
asia wilson did but now i'm like no no
we need you to do that
in asia for you what was it like with
chelsea coming on oh man it's a ton of
fun having her along i couldn't stand
her when she used to play for that other
team in those other colors but she's
here now and i'm just so happy to play
alongside her you guys all look so great
and let's talk tokyo olympics coming
back with the gold medal three years ago
did you ever think you would be playing
an olympics much less gold medal winners
yeah it's been a crazy few years and to
know you know where we started and where
we are now and we were just in tokyo a
couple weeks ago competing at a high
level
how was it playing on the same team with
some more of your competitors like you
don't want to give away too many secrets
but you don't you want to learn their
secrets yeah i mean i feel like at the
end of the day we've known each other
like the back of our hands through
scouts so it's pretty fun to play
alongside them now and to just pick
their brain in the locker room or just
have some fun with them and can we see
the gold you got the gold
did you know if you take that to
chipotle they'll give you free burritos
forever chipotle i'm coming for you
okay maybe that's not true i made that
up but that's pretty cool how many times
do you think you've bitten that medal uh
over 20 times absolutely there's no bite
marks in it too so that means it's a
real deal ladies congratulations you are
such great representatives of this city
we love you and good luck oasis thank
you
back to you guys oh aces go mercedes
that was fun they are so sweet and uh so
asia wilson her favorite restaurant is
chipotle that was a reference that's
where the joke came yes because i was
like is that true no no
we asked chelsea like what's yours and
she's like uh chipotle as well so why
hey if you're a gold medal winner i
think you can go get a free burrito i'm
just saying i feel like if you just go
in there and say look guys
i'm cold yeah would these work
these workers
maybe
why don't you go try it let me know i'll
let you know what happens they kick me
out you gotta follow them on social
media too they're so much fun they're
great ladies the whole team is awesome
so let's send